now the public and commercial services
union took the unprecedented step of
taking part in legal action against the
government over its policy to remove
asylum seekers to rwanda and it's of
course the job of civil servants to
implement the policy putting them on a
collision course with the government we
can talk now to the pcs union general
secretary at mark sawatka who joins us
and now from wales i believe and good to
uh see you on the programme and before
we get to the rwanda case i just want to
talk to you about story in the sunday
telegraph today grant shaps giving an
interview where he says agency workers
could be brought in to effectively break
strikes to cover uh the jobs of striking
workers that would be changing
the law to remove that restriction
what's your reaction
well that would be an outrageous act if
the government go down that road we've
already got the most restrictive
anti-union legislation in the whole of
western europe it's already incredibly
difficult for unions and workers to
withdraw their labor there are so many
legal loopholes to fly through and if
you think about what grant chaps is
trying to do with that legislation is to
make industrial action ineffective and i
believe it's a basic human right to be
able to withdraw your labor you only do
it as a last resort and any attempts to
bring people in to undermine disputes
will not resolve the problems at the end
of the day a dispute happens because
there's disagreement between the
employer and the workforce that
disagreement is not going to be resolved
if people can be brought in to undermine
disputes it will lead to bitterness it
will lead to division and it will lead
to these problems getting worse so what
grandchat should really be doing is
trying to resolve the dispute to ensure
our rail workers frontline public sector
workers have decent paying conditions
they're not threatened with the cutting
their cost of living standards and he
should try to resolve the dispute not
poor petrol on the flames and make
matters worse
you know you say that you know strikes
are the last resort for workers and i
just wonder if you know the government
might feel that this kind of changed the
law is a last resort for itself too
and you know we've heard from the rnt
saying that they're going to call
they're going to call
an unknown number of strikes that could
go on for an unknown number of days or
weeks over the summer it could
potentially haven't ruled out
you know lead to a situation where the
lights go off and do you worry that the
unions might have actually overplayed
their hand a little bit here and that's
why we could be seeing this pushback
from the government
no i think my own view is probably the
unions have underplayed their hand now
over far too many years you know we
we've seen right across trade unions in
the public and private sector terms and
conditions eroded in the civil service
for example we've seen 11 consecutive
years of real terms pay cuts
and the fact that it's so difficult now
to organize lawful industrial action
means all the cards are stacked in the
favor of the government or unscrupulous
employers as we've recently seen with
pno ferries who just similarly dismissed
800 workers and brought people in at
deplorably low levels of pay so the
point of industrial action is that it
gives workers collectively the chance to
stand together to try and get a better
deal
and i think that we have a long and
proud history of the right to strike of
the right of people to defend themselves
as a last resort
and what i would hope that your viewers
would understand sophie is when people
go on strike they lose pay it's the last
thing that they want to do but if a
company is insisting on cutting your pay
cutting your pension cutting your job
for example and they will not listen to
reason it's the last thing you can do
and of course if you're going to
withdraw your labor the point of doing
that is to have an effect to try to get
people back around the negotiating table
so this is a wrong move
on top of already incredibly restrictive
legislation and it will make matters
worse not resolve the problems that we
want to see resolved
uh we spoke to rachel reeves a little
earlier on the programme she refused to
go as far as we're streeting who said
that if he was a member of the rmt he'd
be voting for
strike action and i spoke to mick lynch
on the programme a couple of weeks ago
and he said that he effectively thought
that the labour party weren't showing
there on the side of workers he asked
the question what's the point
of the labour party
do you agree with mick lynch do you
think that their response has been a bit
too bland
well i would certainly like to see a lot
stronger support from the labour party
and of course many in the labour party
have been quite supportive you know
whether that's john mcdonnell or whether
that's leasing andy in recent weeks
but what the labour party are going to
have to do is come up with a position
because the way things are going we're
going to see more industrial action as
the year goes on because people are
facing such a catastrophic cut in their
living standards or in my case
representing people who have been told
one in five ninety one thousand of them
face losing their jobs they're being
told they're getting a 2 pay rise when
inflation is 9 to 11 depending what
index you use we saw the general
secretary of unison the other day say
that she was considering balloting
unison's 1.1 million members so the
labour party will have to decide whose
side they are on and given it was
founded by the trade unions and they are
there to speak up for working men and
women i would hope that we would see kia
stammer and his team fundamentally come
out on the side of nurses doctors job
center workers rail workers and
education workers that's what we want is
a political voice in parliament okay
stands with the people who are having to
take this
difficult stand now of course the pcs
union took the unusual action last week
of trying to stop the government's plan
to send asylum seekers to rwanda you
took court action which she lost the
judge the judge sorry found in favor
of the government to allow that flight
to rwanda to
go ahead
um are you going to be appealing the
decision and do you think that or do you
know except that this flight is going to
go ahead on tuesday
no we're appealing the decision we're in
high court tomorrow appealing the
decision
and as you say this is an unprecedented
step sophie but but let me explain why
we're doing it
we have to test the legality of these
proposals but also we need to debate
about the morality and lack of humanity
that the government is demonstrating
when people are fleeing from iraq or
iran or syria or yemen and they come to
this country they are fleeing death
torture and persecution
we should welcome people to this country
and treat them civilly and assess their
cases when they are here the fact that
people are taking to small boat
crossings in the channel shows how
desperate they are and our members civil
servants 80 of whom we represent in the
border force
don't come to work to be asked to turn
those boats back mid-channel which is
what pretty propel demanded that they
did two months ago and i remind viewers
we went to court then we lost two
injunctions but we would have won the
case which is why the home office
withdrew its policy and let's remember
what pretty patel wanted pcs members to
do was to turn dinghy's back mid-channel
at risk of death that was stopped by a
legal process and that's why we're
taking legal action now
and we hope we win tomorrow in the court
of appeal to stop the flight but of
course the legality of these proposals
will only be tested out at the full
court sharing in july and we're
absolutely confident that in july in
line with what the unhcr said very
graphically in court we believe these
proposals will be found to be unlawful
okay
now i just i i appreciate the sort of
strength of feeling that many will feel
many of our viewers as well about this
policy
i just want to read part of the civil
service code
it says you must not frustrate the
implementation of policies once
decisions are taken
you must serve the government whatever
its political persuasion to the best of
your ability in a way which maintains
political impartiality no matter what
your own political beliefs are
in seeking an injunction to try and stop
this flight you know you're effectively
trying to change and frustrate the
implementation of policy
many would argue that is breaching the
code
well many may argue that of course i
think the first part i would make is
when that civil service code was written
it was based on two fundamental premises
firstly that anything you were asked to
do as a single servant was lawful
we believe that this is not lawful and
the court has yet to determine that's
the case but secondly it presupposes
that the government of the day itself
abides by the rule of law and acts
within the rule of law we know this
government has shown demonstrably he has
not done that and what we saw if we can
just for a minute look at the partygate
proposals is when it came down to it
it's civil servants who were fined it's
civil servants who are now facing
disciplinary action while the prime
minister seems to get away scot-free so
given the government's disregard for the
rule of law and giving it to be fair the
courts have found in favor of the
government or you know the last week
well what they they've not found these
proposals legal what happened last week
was an injunction was refused the
legality of the proposals will not be
determined till july and sophie the
question i would respectfully ask is
imagine if you're a civil servant now in
the home office who goes to work because
you want to see a humane immigration
system where people are treated fairly
and we comply with our international
obligations imagine if you're told to do
something on tuesday that in july is
subsequently found to be illegal that
would be an appalling situation and if
pretty patel had any respect
not just for the desperate people who
come to this country but for the workers
she employs she would not ask a single
one of them to be part of any
deportation of any asylum seeker until
at least these cases are heard in court
for the full legality judgment
will be in july
just finally uh quickly um you rejoined
the labour party in 2016 to support
jeremy corbyn in transforming the party
are you still a member under kyoustama
yes i am okay uh thank you very much uh
indeed mark so walk there
thank you